hello everyone my name is Hillel Wayne
I'm really excited to be presenting this
talk
tackling concurrency bugs with TL A+ you
might notice that the name is a little
bit different from the guide that's
because I think guide book and the
website crashed when you use an actual
plus that's why we had to spell it out
we'll be talking about concurrency why a
lot of our tools do not work to address
it and how we can use tools from formal
specification to address these problems
before we begin though I have a couple
of housekeeping notes first I created a
slack channel TLA plus for anybody who
wants to ask questions or follow up
afterwards you might notice that slack
also has problems with the plus symbol
second housekeeping note some of you
might have noticed this on my profile on
a show of hands how many of you thought
that was a bluff well I brought seven
pounds of sesame brittle that I made so
I do not yeah I made this I do not make
Bluffs and come see me afterwards okay
with that out of the way let's actually
begin so a little bit of background on
me I work for a company called East bark
learning and the product I work on is
also called you spark what we do is at a
very very narrow level students have
iPads we have diagnosis on how good
these students are at various things and
we give them lessons and third-party
apps to help them learn those topics
it's a pretty simple system and nothing
ever goes wrong with it just kidding
this is actually an oversimplification
of what this is and my job of the
company is to make sure that this does
not fall apart if there's a bug it could
be anything from an issue with our
systems a bug in our stuff a bug in some
third party or it could be the school's
Wi-Fi is down or it could be and this
did happen once unfortunately everything
is fine except little Tamiya's friends
played throw your iPad to heaven and
this user hasn't noticed that the iPod
is now just a bunch of duct tape
but naturally if you try to sort of look
at all those issues and fix them one by
one they're going to go insane so it's
more important to look at the broad
scopes of problems and figure out how to
address them in abstract so with that in
mind let's talk about concurrency what
exactly to be my concurrency this is
strange loop and not garage school so
I'm going to give a very rough
definition here concurrency is when you
have multiple systems that are running
independently and they have some sort of
shared or global state
additionally the systems we're
interested in are also non-deterministic
by which we mean that if a happens then
B happens that may have a different
result than B happening in than a
happening one example of this is a
writers and readers from a queue
depending on the orders the writers
write and depending on how long the
readers read from and depending on how
long it takes to process the messages
you could get different results just
based on the time spans alone and this
is actually a big problem for us as
cloud architects because even in the
simplest monolith you have a front end a
back end and a database two points with
currency and you make it vastly vastly
worse if you have a microservice
architecture if that's happening that
you don't have to deal with all the
services talking to each other
independently but you also have to deal
with the fact that the ways they
communicate as concurrency - is it
synchronous asynchronous are using
queues published sub exactly once only
once at most once all sorts of different
problems arise and when you have
concurrency everything falls apart let's
give an example of what I mean imagine
we have a banking system we have Alice
and Bob as account holders in this
banking system Alice wants to wire money
to Bob that's gonna happen a lot just
letting you know the bank also gives us
overdraft protection and what that means
is that Alice cannot wire more money
than she has in her account
what would this algorithm look like in
the abstract here's one way we can do it
step one check if she has enough money
and if not raise step two add to his
account step three
subtract from her account
let's come on a model up this way this
is the diagram we'll be using one check
one plus one minus fortunately the
PowerPoint can handle the plus symbol
now what happens if this isn't atomic
for example what happens if based on
your architecture if you have two wires
happening at the same time one may not
finish before the other one starts that
is a possibility this leads to a thing
we informally call this let's give a
sample volume by the carnival of Horrors
step one race conditions multiple
systems or during causing problems
example here you do both checks before
any subtractions and now you've
overdrafted other things crashes or
partial failure states this is where you
can't guarantee that everything always
runs in this case imagine if after
you've done the addition but before
you've subtracted from Alice's account
you hit the server with a baseball bat
now the transaction stops but now Alice
ABAB both have money we've duplicated
money this is a problem or a third thing
in deadlocks when every system is
waiting for every other system to finish
before anything happens this actually
isn't really relevant to our specific
example but I mentioned it for
completeness sake so instead here's a
drawing of catch-22
so hopefully you can see that we have
problems and we need to fix these
problems now as software developers we
have a lot of tools to fix problems and
find problems most of them actually do
not apply here as much as they wish they
would so with that in mind I'd like to
talk about some of the tools we do have
and why they fail step 1 unit tests not
knocking unit test unit tests are
fantastic I love them I think we should
all be using them if you're not using
them probably more useful than this talk
let's be honest they also just do not
work on doing with concurrency problems
here's an example we have this as a very
simple test when I receive the message
it sends an alert great you can attest
that right how about this this is now
we're adding a lot of different systems
here as well as third-party systems and
timing issues that's gonna be really
hard to set up and you could maybe get
through it with by you just mocking
everything out but let's be honest we're
mocking everything out you're not
actually testing anything and even if
you can set up this entire system note
how we now have three conditions we've
added on given that any combination of
those three conditions could cause a
problem
we now have actually eight tests we have
to write in our wire example we'd have
to write this many given this many wires
going on simultaneously
you had combinational combinatorial
explosion very very quickly when dealing
with multiple systems and are you really
gonna write 18,000 tests thought not so
tests don't quite work here as much as
we'd want them to okay think too static
typing now I was given some very
important advice before starting this
talk which is in strange loop if you say
anything bad about static typing your
talks now about static typing so with
that in mind static typing is absolutely
perfect there's nothing wrong with it
you can use type
you can use magic you can use type
systems to imagine through with every
concurrency bug from your problem you
will never have any concurrency bugs
ever in any of your programs but again
we're cloud engineers we're talking to
other people's programs too and they're
not as enlightened as we are they're
gonna have bugs because they're not
using magic type systems so and when
their stuff breaks it's gonna cause your
stuff to break and can you really go to
the customer when they complain hey
everything's broken and you tell them
well MongoDB is known to just randomly
drop data and that's why your cat
exploded it's their fault
they're not going to accept that are
they and finally purity we don't get
purity work we're cloud engineers we're
trying to we're trying to cause side
effects we're trying to mutate the world
like we just do not get the ability to
say that we're using only pure functions
so there's of course other things too
I'd be happy to afterwards to talk about
why they all fail to but generally most
of the techniques we have to verify code
is correct just don't apply here and
that's because we've actually been
looking at this wrong the whole time at
least in this talk see all those things
we talked about were ways of verifying
code works but there wasn't anything
wrong with our code there was a problem
with our system the code was fine it's
just that we allowed crashes to happen
outside of the code if servers could not
crash we couldn't do we would not be
able to duplicate money of course
Assen that servers don't crash is
absolutely insane we live in the real
world servers crash all the time but it
does mean that we can make possible
changes to our system to prevent these
problems from happening one example see
how we had three steps what if there's
only two what if the addition of the
subtraction of the wire happened in the
exact same time we can notify it like
this maybe that would fix our bug maybe
that would make it impossible to
duplicate money by crashing things now
how do we notice we can start by
informally verifying with pencil and
paper and that's gonna require a lot of
manual labor so it's time to roll up our
sleeves grab some coffee and ask the
intern to do it let's go through all the
possibilities or at least let's make the
intern go through all the possibilities
no crush at all no problem crashes
immediately not great but no duplication
of money right crashes right after the
check same thing
crashes after this transfer but before
you've done any cleanup also not great
but the transfer is done you've not
duplicated money there's no way for the
crash to happen in between at the
addition and subtraction under the
system so we can be confident that if we
implement this correctly and we'd have
to make sure our code matched this idea
that we wouldn't have the bug now we
could also apply this to our other
problem let's say the race condition
where we overdrafted but that has a lot
more cases we have to look at and
because of that we have to step back a
bit we as engineers have always realized
one thing which is that a lot of things
are boring and we don't like boring
things when whenever we can we use
computers to do the boring stuff for us
not only because they are willing to do
it they can't say no but also because
they're less likely to make mistakes I
knew that if I was trying to verify 24
different possible behaviors I would
make at least one mistake there so what
we want is a way to take this idea of
looking at a system looking at how we've
ridden the system and going through
pencil and paper and writing down every
possible scenario and see if they all
match what we do this a computer is
something called formal specification
specification because it accurately
describes our system so well that a
machine can understand it and formal
because it is so precise that we can
objectively unambiguously say whether or
not any conditions are broken
now one thing I have to make clear that
I find that a lot of people find
confusing this is not our code we when
we write the specification we're
validating our blueprints for validating
our design in our heads or architecture
we still have to make sure that we've
implemented the specification correctly
in code that is one of the limitations
it's the price you have to pay for
flexibility and power of course I'm now
just talking on abstract let's actually
go into details of a specification
system the one I prefer and the focus of
this talk is T la plus che le plus was
invented by Leslie Lamport in 1994
otherwise Lamport is known for the Paxos
algorithm most of his works on
distributed systems and inventing law
tech he had the idea that with the power
of mathematics it may be possible to
create specifications that would be very
difficult or impossible do in
programming languages what that means
again theory lots of theory going to
skip that instead it'll be a lot easier
to show you an example of what I mean so
what we're going to do is we're going to
use TL A+ to specify first our simple
transaction transfer and show that that
works without any changes to the
structure and then we're going to add
the additional possible wires happening
simultaneously and so that I can find
that bug a couple of housekeeping notes
again first of all because this uses a
lot of a lot of law tech notation I'm
going to be walking through some of the
what are they called
operators etc they're not normal
programming operators I will be calling
them out and the second is that while
tailee plus is what drives this what I
write it and what a lot of people
actually write it is a language called
plus cow which Lamport invented about 15
years later it's more programming like
and it compiles down to TL a plus
kind of like how C compiles to assembly
now let's go through our example first
of all we have first of all we have
Alice and Bob they both have accounts we
will say that they each have $10 we're
going to have an algorithm and then
we're to say what properties of our
system we want here's one way we can say
what we want this is called an invariant
it is something that must be
every step of our system no overdrafts
is defined as the double equals is
defined as Alice has zero or more
dollars and Bob has zero more dollars
this is normal set notation you can
actually write the unicode - I prefer
not to and when we read our algorithm we
can check this no overdrafts except that
this right now doesn't scale it doesn't
actually represent our transfer system
because what if we adds say Carey or
Dave
we have to update our overdrafts
invariant so what we'll do instead is
start leveraging what we mean by math is
more expressive than programs step one
we're going to change our setup a bit
instead of having it two distinct
variables for each account we have a set
of people and a function from people to
the number 10 and that means that for
every person in a set of people account
of that people is ten note that ta plus
functions are not the same as
programming functions
kailia plus functions are mathematical
functions they map a domain of inputs to
a range of outputs in other words they
are just like PHP s arrays PHP is
cutting-edge mathematics fun fact
and with this in mind we can now write
our invariant like this for all P and
instead of P in the set of people the
account of P is going to be at least 0
and now note that when we write it this
way even if we say at a hundred people
to the set of people the account will
still have all them equal 10 and the
overdrafts on variant will still be
correct and represent our system with
that in mind let's now actually write
our algorithm first of all we have a
process that is the part of the code
that actually runs and does stuff we
have the variables of the process how
much we want to transfer $1 from whom to
whom and then we actually have the code
if they have enough money then you add
to their account and subtract from your
account this is pretty standard stuff
with the only thing that might be
unusual are these these are called
labels they represent atomic units of
time
what that means is that everything
inside the label runs instantly and then
the TLA plus can say some other process
is allowed to interrupt we will see once
we specify multiple transfers what this
actually looks like with that in mind
though we now have enough to actually
test this system first we have to use
the IDE the ID is called ta+ toolbox and
combines all the tools we use for this
we use that first to compile this into
ti+ this is what the spec looks like in
TLA plus hopefully you can see why I
prefer plus Cal now then we have to
specify our model the model shows all
the runtime aspects for us the only
thing we really care pardon bigger fonts
unfortunately not right now but that is
the point yep that's the point that I
wanted people to focus on which is that
the invariant we say that we specify
that the invariant is going to be no
overdrafts and we said that as the thing
we're actually going to check my
apologies for the small fonts I could
actually let me see if I can actually
umm yeah and that's I prefer PowerPoint
to Google slides I'm honest it's just
been a lot nicer to like working so then
we have there are no over drafts that
we're specifying and with that in mind
we can actually now check our model the
tool we use is called TLC TLC is an
exhaustive brute-force ER it looks at
all possible paths through our
specification and through that season
any of them have any bugs actually
here's a fun little exercise can anybody
guess what TLC stands for anyone well
turns out nobody knows I'm serious about
this I read all the papers on TLC and
Tilly Plus none of them mention what
expands to I've read all of the books on
it nobody mentions it I asked the news
group and nobody can remember I think it
stands for temporal logic checker but
for all I know it's the Lifetime channel
okay even so it's still a fantastic
piece of machinery so let's actually now
run our model I will do this to run it
hopefully that works no that's not
working but I am finding that it's kind
of hard to this demo there we go and
this is what it looks like when it runs
so you can see there have been no bugs
and our spec is perfect now that we've
done that let's now break it let's add
the multiple possible simultaneous wires
to do that we have to make two changes
first of all you see how we set that
amount is going to be equal to one right
over there
I don't like that let's now say that the
amount is going to be some integer in
the set of numbers from 1 to 10 and now
instead of having one possible starting
state we now have 10 TLC we'll have to
check all 10 initial States and make
sure none of them break our invariant
change too you see how the transfer we
say that transfer is just going to be 1
don't like that either let's now say
it's in the set of 2 elements blue and
green there's now blue transfer and a
green transfer these may run one after
another they may will run sequentially
but however they can organize through
the labels till a plus we'll have to
check every possible ordering
additionally while they have a global
state they share each defines as local
variables so each one can choose a
different amount instead of having one
state ten states we have to check now we
now have a hundred initial States and
beyond that we now have multiple
behaviors for each possible starting
state if the blue transfer if the blue
check runs first we can have the blue
addition to happen after or we can have
the green check we can do this all the
way through and end up with 24 possible
behaviors that times 100 initial States
involves 2,400 total behaviors we need
to check
make sure that none of them have any
mistakes so let's do that let's check
all 2,400 and found an error I'm gonna
be honest I want to do a sad trombone
but it was hard to bring in a trombone
than a kazoo so what happens is that TLC
was able to look at all of our states
and find one that violated our invariant
it also provided an error trace to show
the setup and the resolution that led to
this problem happening I'm going to walk
you through it step one we have the
setup they have note is that we have
this as our initial setup the thing to
note here is that the amount is that the
blue transfer is going to transfer one
dollar the green transfer will be
transferring ten dollars then we have
our first steps the main thing is is
that the blue check in addition run but
the subtraction has not run else is ten
dollars of Bob has 11 but because we
haven't subtracted money yet now the
green check can happen and that green
check can pass the check because she
still has ten dollars but then the blue
subtraction happens she only has nine
now but the green check has already
happened it's capable of going through
and doing it subtraction to Alice now is
negative one dollars and we have
violated the overdrafts invariant we can
now make a change to our system and see
if that works one change we can make is
that we can say that everything it
happens in the same database transaction
then we can run this to see if this
works
spoiler it does alternatively maybe we
can't say that maybe we're using a bad
database but we can find some other way
maybe using a caching layer if so we
could try that make those changes and
see if that works
of course we'd self to implement this in
the code and we'd have to make sure we
are writing the code correctly but even
so what we've done here is found and
fixed a bug without having even started
to write code we're finding bugs and
fixing them in the system itself that's
pretty cool
but let's oh no I'm still going but
let's be honest who cares by which I
mean I'm sure everybody here has seen
demo itis which is where something looks
really cool in a presentation just like
this one and then is utterly useless in
practice I have a lot of those I will
talk afterwards about them I have made
many mistakes learning things but so
what I want to do here is show that this
is actually not just possible but
practical and to do so I want to list a
couple three different use cases that we
found at our work where this has
actually solved real problems for us
these are going to be broad overviews
because I really do not want to have to
walk you through all of our business
logic but hopefully it'll give you
enough of an insight to see why I find
it so interesting first case was a
greenfield project the app sinker this
is actually our first use of TL a-plus
and practice what we had was we had to
talk to a third party API to install
applications on devices but in order to
sort of make this performant we had to
do this in a synchronous worker
additionally due to some serious bugs in
their system we could not send as many
commands as we wanted we had to minimize
the number of commands we could send
them and finally we found out they had
this one more requirement if we tried to
install an app that was already
installed that we would cause a memory
leak turns out their entire system was
an idempotent
so we had a spike that we did that we
thought fixed these issues but before
continuing we decided that we should
probably model this out until A+ this is
what this particular invariant looked
like in TLA plus for all D in the set of
devices the install count is either 0 or
1
it cannot be we can't install more than
one time we cannot remove it more than
one time we thought we had a pretty good
system built but it found a bug in it
this bug was a fairly an early one
involving two different workers doing
different things but overlapping in the
time range they really shouldn't have
but could it would have led to breaking
our contract it would have led to us
doing non idempotent installs which
would have been very bad
it would have also been the kind of bug
that would have taken us a week to find
in production but when we found it with
this it was only five minutes to change
our overall architecture to make sure
this never happened when we did
implement it we didn't ever saw that bug
ever occur and that was what really
slowly something idea that this could
actually be practical case to
documentation we had the system running
for a while a way of doing zero down
down deployments what we mean is a way
of updating the servers in our load
balancer such that our app is always
available but a client cannot see the
same app cannot see the same code in
different versions they cannot see
flickering code we had already got this
working but we did we did as an exercise
as we specified this into a light Plus
this is what the environment looked like
there exists a server and the load
balancer such that it is not updating
and it matches every other servers
version this one did not find any bugs
because again battle-tested system but
what it did provide us was a very very
compact documentation of the overall
design and what happened was another
team is now implementing a zero downtime
deployment and our other project and we
were able to give them our specification
as a broad architecture of how our
algorithm works it was a way of
transferring knowledge and the third
case our most recent is in the redacted
system it's not actually redacted that's
just the name I gave it never let me
name things and this is where we can
talk about in an existing system finding
bugs when we try to change it I'm not
going to go into too much detail but we
have multiple sources sending messages
to a large pool of messages and we have
multiple workers reading out these
messages and doing the long-running
processes based on them we had if we had
the system already partially working and
we had some invariance it's satisfied
and then our project manager was like
hey we have a new requirement when a
worker processes from a source it isn't
allowed to switch to a different source
of messages on toast finished all the
messages that are existing in the pool
of the existing source that might be a
little bit ambiguous or a little bit
awkward to say this is what ended up
looking like
Esmond very
four lines for every worker in the set
if it is on a source and there still
remaining messages it's not a lot to
change to a different source and of
course it found a pretty early
architecture bug that we hadn't
implemented yet again not gonna go into
the details and we had again a very
simple fix but remember how he said that
we already had some invariants that it
satisfied turns out that every fix we
could find broke a different environment
and in fact now I did it break a
different invariant it broke that
invariant in a way that required 17
steps to reproduce the error we were
unable to find a simple way of
reproducing this that didn't require an
insane amount of complication and all
the changed simple changes we thought
that would be easy intuitive changes to
make retroactive we broke the old
invariants this was showing us that we
did not understand her system well
enough to do both invariants at once
eventually we came back to the project
manager and we're like okay we figured
it out either we relaxed the old
invariants we relaxed the new invariant
or you give us two months to completely
redesign everything we relaxed the old
invariants so not only did be able to
model us give us a deep understanding of
what we need to change it saved us a lot
of work that was pretty cool
so hopefully this should be enough to
sort of show you that this is at least
worth exploring that this is an
interesting idea and that Leslie Lamport
for inventing this is this terrifying
scary man so with this last section I
would like to talk about where to get
started the first resource is mine this
is something I wrote called learn
Telecom and what it is is it is a
beginner level introduction to using ta+
and specifying it assumes no initial
knowledge and all the exercises and
examples are designed to be practical
use cases for example when talking about
currency the example I use is not going
over a rate limiter at the same time it
only covers the 30 percent of the
simplest part of PLA Plus still enough
to do some really great stuff but not
exactly at an advanced level that's
intentional and a limitation
more advanced than that is the canonical
and only book on ela + specifying system
is by Leslie Lamport he is working on a
sequel called the hyper book but that's
still in progress so I'm a little bit
reluctant to fully recommend it it is
the canonical text and covers almost the
entire range of PLA plus including the
theory
most of the remain most of the library
packages it does not use plus Cal LAN
port invented about five years after he
wrote this book and the send
intermediate level and in the final
resource if your interest in the
abstract theory is Chile plus in theory
and practice
Ron Presler is actually the person who
got me interested in this in the first
place and he's written a deep dive into
the temporal logic that underpins TLA
plus it's not focused on the actual use
of it in day-to-day life but it's a good
thing to read if you're interested in
sort of how this works
from the bottom up and with that thank
you so much for coming I'm hello Elaine
find me after if you have any questions
or you just want some food
[Applause]